jetzt mal was schönes seit dieser woche
gibt es endlich hoffnung für den
geschundenen gedemütigten deutschen vw
käufer das oberlandesgericht
braunschweig verhandelt unsere erste
muster feststellungsklage 470.000 diesel
käufer haben sich da zusammen
geschlossen für mich allesamt echte
helden des alltags eindeutig ja im
erfolgsfall müsste zwar jeder einzelne
noch mal selber klagen aber trotzdem
wird dann natürlich gerade
rechtsgeschichte geschrieben wird ein
mega event dieser prozess extra verlegt
in die stadthalle
wobei mich die zdf berichterstattung
hier relativ ratlos macht der andrang
zum auftakt des mammutprozesses ist
enorm berichtet elisabeth schmid der
anderen vor der stadtteil der
braunschweig hält sich in grenzen
fassen wir zusammen es war brechend voll
in der fast leeren stadthalle und das
ist leider symptomatisch viele deutsche
sind doch nur noch müde beim thema abgas
betrug andererseits muss man dazu sagen
geht es an so einem ersten prozesstag
natürlich vor allem um verfahrensfragen
das ist mehr etwas für fachleute für
connaisseure einer der neutralen anwälte
die dieses verfahren beobachten sagte
heute nachmittag ist das was wir erleben
hardcore jura hardcore while hardcore
jura zufälligerweise auch der titel
eines berühmten gedichts pornos
hardcore-gamer massenklage im
gerichtssaal
ja
ganz ehrlich gesagt weiß ich als
nichtjurist als laie gar nicht was sie
da jetzt monatelang verhandeln wollen in
braunschweig
es soll geklärt werden ob vw mit einer
illegalen software die kunden zitat
vorsätzlich und sittenwidrig geschädigt
hat die entschuldigung was denn sonst
us-gericht man kann gar nicht an den
rechner stolpern und dann aus versehen
jahrelangen schummel software
programmieren ohne eigene schulen
software was mache ich denn man kann
diese software übrigens auch nicht aus
versehen im millionen von autos einbauen
und diese autos dann millionen kunden
aus versehen für viel geld verkaufen das
alles geht tatsächlich nur vorsätzlich
mit voller absicht und weil man ein
gieriger us konzern ist an den hals
nicht voll kriegen
[Applaus]
juli fortsetzen tatsache ist ja einen
sauberen diesel hätte man natürlich
schon vor jahren bauen können aber das
war vw hat zu teuer
in den usa zahlen sie fette strafen in
australien haben sie sich gerade erst
auf einen vergleich mit den kunden
geeinigt nur wir deutschen sollen
ich nehme an aus patriotismus leer
ausgehen und die miese luftweg atmen uns
idioten sagt vw cup 3 ist noch heute
werden die fahrzeuge hunderttausendfach
von den kunden genutzt
wir meinen daher es gibt keinen schaden
es gibt keinen schaden hat den schaden
oder was das gibt's doch gar nicht vw
hat den leuten ein angeblich sauberes
auto verkauft das aber gar nicht sauber
ist ende
was sind das für eine botschaft an die
betrogenen kunden einfach fresse halten
und weiter fahren
was stellen sie sich vor aber
selbstverständlich selbstverständlich
entsteht da schaden da entsteht
wertverlust oder es gibt solche
schicksale hier
wir haben eur 4 die von wohlen in
stuttgart wäscht
das heißt wir können nicht einmal mehr
parken vor unserem haus gut zyniker
würden fragen warum zieht man aus
stuttgart west aber das ist ja gar nicht
das thema
das ist nicht das thema vw hofft
natürlich geben sie sogar zu dass sich
das verfahren noch lange hinzieht
möglichst über jahre weil die
nutzungszeit der fahrzeuge vom
schadenersatz abgezogen wird wissen sie
was fair wäre wenn vw da so einen drive
in schalter auf macht und dann fahren da
alle 470.000 kläger vorbei jeder kriegt
sich 30.000 euro putzen cheeseburger und
dann kommt ein vw vorstand putz die
windschutzscheibe und entschuldigt sich
mit einem song von elton john
[Musik]
das wäre das mindeste freunde nur mal
als idee spannende wochen also für
volkswagen zumal hier haben sie
garantiert gelesen die
staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig auch
noch anklage erhoben hat gegen den ex vw
chef winterkorn plus die noch
amtierenden chefs page und dies bekannt
aus dem hörspiel die drei fragezeichen
und die rätselhafte software den wird
vorgeworfen sie hätten die aktionäre zu
spät über ihren diese betrug informiert
ergo werden was gelernt kunden darf man
verarschen aber nicht die aktionäre aber
das erfahren sie alles in der
fortsetzung die drei fragezeichen das
geheimnis der vergitterten fenster
oder sind die drei etwa unschuldig vw
beantwortet heute keine nachfragen der
presse die für gute unternehmensführung
zuständige vorstandsfrau belässt es bei
einer videobotschaft
die vorwürfe sind unbegründet die
volkswagen ag ist dementsprechend
weiterhin der festen überzeugung alle
kapitalmarktrechtlichen
informationspflichten erfüllt zu haben
wir haben alles richtig gemacht
ja sie lange bei den e autos ist vw echt
hinten dran aber ihre sprechenden
roboter sind 1
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt wird also herbert diess diesen
wolfsburger weltkonzern von der
anklagebank ausführen das ist wirklich
gangsters münsters teil
passend dazu hat das landgericht
düsseldorf gerade vor einer woche
festgestellt ganz offiziell festgestellt
auch die sogenannten thermo fenster die
vw und sein angeblich saubere software
update einbaut seien illegal
ja das schaltet sich die abgasreinigung
ab wenn es zum beispiel kälter ist als
zehn grad
was hier in deutschland zum glück nie
vorkommt meine damen und herren ja
solche fenster sind laut eu recht nur in
absoluten ausnahmefällen erlaubt zum
motorschutz trotzdem hat das
kraftfahrtbundesamt das so abgenickt
bezeichnet die reaktion eines
fondsmanagers in der wolfsburger
zentrale auf die software freigaben in
einer e mail schreibt er an seine
mitarbeiter halleluja ich gebe ein neues
avw- musik keine sorgen machen
der deutsche kunde ist nicht nachtragend
aktuellen zahlen aus dieser woche im
september hat volkswagen doppelt so
viele fahrzeuge verkauft wie im
september des letzten jahres es ist fast
allen vum befreundet wobei ich behaupte
wenn herauskäme dass vw bei den ps
zahlen manipuliert dann hätten die drei
sekunden später ein mob mit fackeln und
mistgabeln vor der tür
aber was ich wirklich gar nicht mehr
fassen kann was ich wirklich überhaupt
erfassen kann ist diese nutzlose behörde
da oben in flensburg und da bin ich
nicht der einzige
gernot hassknecht präsentiert wozu
hatten wir das eigentlich nochmal heute
das kraftfahrtbundesamt verschickt zum
einkommen in aktuellen flensburg
reiseführern wird das hier das
kraftfahrtbundesamt als sehenswürdigkeit
genannt er muss man über flensburg mich
wissen das kba hat jahrelang autos mit
betrüger software zugelassen dasselbe
gnadenlose kba dass wir zwei punkte
verpasst wenn ich an meinem siebzigsten
einmal nackt mit dem mofa zur des
rennens überhaupt nicht erinnern kann
wenn das kba mal aus versehen eine
illegale abschalt einrichtung entdeckt
krieg der autohersteller einen bescheid
aber der käufer erfährt nichts und
journalisten die akten sehen wollen
brauchen echt geduld fast zweieinhalb
jahre später schickt uns das
kraftfahrtbundesamt und diese acht
aktenordner zum software-update von vw
fast alle seiten sind geschwärzt genauer
von über 5.000 seiten
sind genau 27 seiten ungeschwärzt 27
seiten und das waren hauptsächlich
bilder wo kba mitarbeiter sich auf den
kopierer gesetzt hatten
natürlich genehmigen die vögel auch
bekannte thermo fenster macht sinn wo
doch der chef von dem laden briefe gerne
so unterschreibt mit industrie
freundlichem gruß ein witz vorschlag die
leute in dieser hässlichen kurze dürfen
weitermachen werden aber abzufahren
direkt von der autoindustrie bezahlt der
jahres etat liegt bei 93 millionen euro
dafür könnte man ich habe im netz
recherchieren 33 millionen 212.000 duft
bäume mit latschenkiefer aroma kaufen
kostet euch zeigt das selbe und man tut
weit mehr für die gute luft so und jetzt
sehe ich mich aus und brettern mit
meiner mutter nach hause
[Applaus]
guten tag ich könnte ich sie für ein abo
des heute show you tube kanal als
begeistern schließt gefälligst ein abo
ab sofort